من دبي سمؤال المتحدث الاقليمي باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه اهلا بك سيد سموال
يعني كيف استقبلت الولايات المتحده مثل
هذا الخطاب الروسي اليوم
التعليق خطوه تعليق مشاركه روسيا في هذه
المعاهده الاستراتيجيه واشنطن وصفتها
بالخطوه المؤسفه لكن ما الذي يمكن ان
يترتب عليها امريكيا وغربيا
اذا مساء الخير وشكرا الجزيره الاستضافه
وفعلا الخطاب المهيم اليوم كان خطاب من
رئيس بايدن ونحن لا نرى ان هذه الحرب
الروسيه الوحشيه الاعشاب الاوكراني شي وجه
لويشه الولايات المتحده الروسيه لا نحن
نعرف ان الان الروسيه كالدوله معزوله عن
العالم فعلا
ونحن نرى ان في الامم المتحده اكثر من 140
دوله كان تسود مع الاوكرانيين اكثر من
خمسين دوله تقدم المساعده الدفاعيه
وعسكريه للاوكرانيين وحتى الدول التي تقدم
ونحن نعرف ان دول مثل كوريا الشماليه
وايران تقدم اسلحه للروس حتى هذه الدوله
تقوم بنفع هذا اذا ليس هناك اي دوله الذي
تقف جانب الروس وجانب الرئيس بوتين في هذه
الحرب بدون بالنسبه هذه الخطوه كما سمعنا
من وزير بلينكن خطوه مؤسفه وغير مسؤوله
لان ليس اي تحديد للولايه المتحده لدينا
الامكانيه للدفاع عن النفس نحن سناخذ كل
الاجراءات اللازمه لدفع عن الناس بالنسبه
هذه هي التحديات تهديدات الجديده من روسيا
حول الاسلحه النوويه ولكن هي فعلا تمثل
خطوره وتماثل تهديدات للعالم ليس هناك اي
دوله التي تريد ان ترى اي حرب نوويه بين
الروسيه وايضا اخرى اذا نحن نرى ان هذه
الخطاب والكلمات والخطوات من الجانب
الروسي فعلا المؤسفه وغير مسؤوله وهي خطوه
اخرى
المبادئ الاساسيه الدوليه التي كنا كنا
نتفق عليها منذ اكثر من 80 سنه طيب تقول
بانها يعني خطوات للدفاع عن النفس يتخذها
الاوكرانيون والغرب وبانها تمثل خطوره
همم تهديدات للعالم معنى ذلك بان الغرب
ياخذ كل هذه التصريحات على محمل الجد كيف
يمكن ان يتصرف الغرب وتكون خطوتها
المقابله او المقبله مقابل هذه التصريحات
وهذه التهديدات للعالم
اذا من جانب بالولد المتحده لا نرى حتى
الان اي سبب
لتغير موقفنا تغير كيف نحن نتعامل مع
الاسلحه النوويه واي تغييرات في موقفنا
لان لدينا الامكانيه للدفاع عن النفس انا
لا اريد ان ادخل في التفاصيل بالنسبه
الجيش
لوزاره الدفاع ولكن بشكل عام نحن لدينا
الامكانيه للدفاع الناس ولذلك من الازمان
اقول ان هذه هي الكلمات والخطاب من رئيس
بوتين غير مسؤول مثل الابتدائيات من هذه
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا على بقيه
العالم بالنسبه امن الغذائي والنقص في
القمح والهبوب والازمه الطاقه ان كل هذه
تؤثر ليس على الولايات المتحده ولكن على
بقيه العالم على الدوله
دوله معزوله ولكن يعني لا يبدو ان روسيا
تقل اليوم صرح بوتا بان هناك خطوات من نوع
اتخاذ او استعداد
اوامر للاستعداد لاجراء اختبارات نوويه
وانت تقول بان الموقف لم يتغير موقف الغرب
لم يتغير لكن مقابل خطوات بهذه الخطوره هل
سيبقى موقف الغرب على حاله
اذا كما ذكرنا لدينا من الولايات المتحده
نتكلم محول الغرب او باسم الغرب بشكل عام
انا نعطيك رسمي في وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه المتحده بالطبع معها الغرب
بالطبع لكن انت يعني من جانب الولايات
المتحده ما الذي يمكن ان تفعله
كما ذكرنا لدينا الامكانيه للدفاع عن
الناس ونحن نعرف التفاصيل بالنسبه الاسلحه
النوويه لديها الروسيه ولدينا وهذا كان
الهدف وراء هذا المؤهل
لنعرف ان الاسلحه النوويه
لنتجنب اي امكانيه لاي دوله ان تستخدم
الاسلحه النوويه اذا لماذا في هذا الوقت
بعد سنوات من كوفيد 19 وارتدائيه الاقتصاد
وتغير المناخ وكل هذه الهروب لماذا الان
روسيا تختار ان تتكلم تتحدث عن الاسلحه
النوويه لا غير مسؤول اشكرك سما والبر
المتحدث الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه كنت معنا
من دبي الخارجيه الامريكيه بالطباب